METE ATAMEL: Hello.
MARC COHEN: Hello.
METE ATAMEL: It's great to
see so many of you here.
My name is Mete Atamel.
I am a developer advocate
at Google based in London.
MARC COHEN: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
METE ATAMEL: I don't
know what you said,
but hopefully it
was something good.
MARC COHEN: I'm not totally
sure either but I think I said,
good morning.
I'm Marc, and I welcome
you to our session.
METE ATAMEL: Great.
So first of all, before
we start our talk,
you might be wondering,
what's a developer advocate?
One of my coworkers and a
good friend of mine, Philippe
[? Hoffa-- ?] you
might know him--
he basically says a developer
advocate is a software engineer
who has license to speak.
I think that kind of
captures what we do.
We are software
engineers by experience,
but we come to events like
this and talk about Google
Cloud-related technologies.
At the same time, we
want to get your feedback
and bring that back
to engineering.
So after this talk, we
have office hours Level 3.
So if you have any questions
or any feedback about Google
Cloud, please come and see us.
So today, we're going to
talk about fundamentals
of Google Cloud Platform.
With have a bit.ly
for the slides.
So if you want the slides,
just get it from there.
And I've been with Google
for one and a half years,
but Marc has been
around more than me.
I think he has been
there since 2011.
So, Marc, do you want to tell
us about those good old days
in 2011, how it was?
MARC COHEN: Sure.
So back when I started, Google
Cloud Platform was quite a bit
simpler.
This is actually what
the Platform website
looked like in 2012.
There were four products--
App Engine, Compute Engine,
Cloud Storage, and BigQuery.
It was really nice and easy.
You knew exactly which
tool to use for which job.
You could really get your
head around the entire product
offering.
So those were kind of the
good old days, for me.
This is what it's like nowadays.
We have more than 60 Google
Cloud product services,
and so many that I can't even
fit them all on one slide.
So there's a lot of
choices out there.
METE ATAMEL: Well,
that's good, right, Marc?
I mean, more services,
more tools, more choice,
that can be only good, right?
MARC COHEN: Well, it's kind
of a mixed bag actually.
The good news is we have
tons of capabilities.
So you can build almost
anything you can imagine now,
and it's a very
powerful platform.
But the downside is there's
kind of a high cognitive
load associated with
all that choice.
You have to actually
think a little bit more
and understand a little
bit more to figure out
which tool to use, when to
use it, and how to use it.
Greg Wilson came up with
this chart, which I think
is a really nice reference.
And by the way, for anybody
that is photographing,
we do have these slides
online right now.
So we'll share this
with you after.
I mean, feel free to photograph,
but we'll share this with you.
It's actually up now.
But this chart summarizes every
cloud product, every Google
Cloud product, in
four words or less.
So it's a really nice synopsis.
Today, we're going to focus
on the four highlighted areas.
And even there, we're
not going to get
to go too deeply because we
have 30 minutes to cover all
this stuff, and each
of these products
we could spend hours on it.
But we'll focus on
those four areas.
We'll probably touch
on a few others.
And we'll try to
just kind of give you
a high-level view,
essentially a roadmap,
of all the capabilities
of Google Cloud Platform.
METE ATAMEL: All right.
First, let's talk about Compute.
I heard that in Keynote
there was a Compute section,
so this will be a bit
of a repetition of that.
But hopefully there
will be some new stuff.
So what we're trying to answer
here is, if you have some code
and you want to run on Google
Cloud, what options do we have?
That's what we are
trying to answer.
At the high level, you
have three separate buckets
when it comes to how
to deploy your code.
The first one is
virtual machines.
So you can think of these
as physical machines
except they're virtualized
and they're running
in someone else's data center.
So you can pick
and choose the CPU
you want, the memory
you want, and then
you also get to choose
the operating system.
It can be Linux-based
or Windows-based.
And then, once you
have the machine,
you can install
whatever you want.
So you have full control,
but at the same time
you have full responsibility
with virtual machines.
So virtual machines
are great, but they're
kind of heavyweight
because you need
to virtualize the whole
operating system and everything
that comes on top of that.
So more recently, we have
something called containers.
So the idea with containers is
that, instead of virtualizing
the operating system, you're
virtualizing the actual process
that your application runs.
So you're virtualizing
your application
and it's dependencies.
And from there, you
create a container image,
and this container image
is much more lightweight
than virtual machines.
So containers are really
easy to move around.
They're really fast to start.
So they're a much
quicker and agile way
of running your applications.
And if you're like
me, you usually
don't care about infrastructure.
You don't want to care
about virtual machines.
You don't want to
care about containers.
You just want to
deploy your code
and let someone else
manage that for you.
So that's when
serverless comes in.
In serverless, literally
just create a function,
deploy it, and let someone
else scale it for you,
run it for you, all
that kind of stuff.
MARC COHEN: So as
Mete just said,
containers have really
changed everything.
And that's another thing that
I've noticed over the last five
years has had a huge impact
on the entire industry
and the cloud in particular.
It kind of really
picked up steam
when Docker was
released in 2013.
So containers really
enable a bunch of things
that we didn't have before,
but containers by themselves
are not enough.
If you think about
deploying your applications
in containers,
these are entirely
self-contained
modular units that you
can kind of scale incrementally,
it's all wonderful.
But if you have a complex
application with, say,
a bunch of front-end servers,
a bunch of back-end database
servers, maybe some
middleware, it's
complicated to get all that
stuff to work together,
to monitor it, to restart
things when they fail.
And that's where
orchestrators come in.
So we've got a kind of
a new breed of software,
container orchestration,
the most popular one
being Kubernetes.
And then another
piece that you kind of
have to reinvent if
somebody hasn't created
a nice pattern for you to reuse
is the service access layer.
So if you want to apply
some security policies,
telemetry, capture
analytics, customize
how your service
is accessed, it's
really nice to have a
service layer on top of it.
And that's Istio is all
about as a service mesh.
And so the combination of all
these innovations together--
containers, orchestrators,
and a service mesh--
really gives you a very powerful
way to manage and deploy
your apps, especially
in the cloud.
METE ATAMEL: Yep.
So now let's look
at what you have
on Google Cloud as products
to deploy applications.
The first thing that
you want to decide
is how much
customization you want
and how much
management you want.
So there is this spectrum.
The more highly managed things
are, the less customizable
they are usually.
Or if you want
things to customized,
then they are not
so highly managed
because you have to
maintain that yourself.
So if you want to have
things customizable,
you have Compute Engine.
So the idea of the
Compute Engine,
as you heard before
at the Keynote,
is that you got a
VM with an operating
system with certain CPU
and memory that you choose.
And then once you have
the VM, it's yours.
You can do whatever
you want with it.
So you only get the
machine and then
the operating system with it.
At some point, you might want
to put some software on it.
So one way of doing
that is that you can
install that yourself manually.
But we also have something
called Cloud Launcher.
It's kind of like a
marketplace for solutions
to deploy to Google Cloud.
So you can install things like
MongoDB, ASP.NET Framework,
and there's a bunch
of other solutions
from Google and
from outside Google.
So the idea of Cloud Launcher
is that with one click
you can get a solution
deployed to Compute Engine.
So just let me show you
some of this quickly.
So here I am in
Google Cloud Console.
You've probably
seen this before.
On the left, we have a bunch
of products on Google Cloud,
but the one that
we are interested
is in the Compute Engine.
So on Compute Engine
instance, I can see my VMs,
and then these are the VMs
that I have already running.
If I want to create a VM, I just
do a Create Instance and this
takes me to a new page.
So I'll give you
my instance a name.
So let's call this
instance GDD Krakow.
And then you can
choose your zone.
So we have zones
all over the world,
but since we're in Europe
let's choose Europe West.
So for machine type,
you can customize it.
So you can pick and choose
how many cores you want
and how much memory you
want all the way from one
CPU to 64 CPUs.
You can also choose already
preconfigured instances.
So I'm just going to choose
an N1 standard, which has one
CPU and four gigs of memory.
After that, you can choose
what kind of operating system
you want.
So we have all different flavors
of Linux, from Debian, CoreOS,
container-optimized operating
systems, even Windows servers--
2008, 2012, 2016.
You can even install
applications.
So if you want to have
SQL Server for example,
under Application Images
you can install that.
So I'll just choose
a standard Linux
instance-- let's say Debian 9.
And then you can allow
HTTPS and Create.
And this will give me a
VM within a few seconds.
So I have a Linux
VM already running.
You can easily SSH into that.
Just click this button, and you
don't have to worry about keys.
Everything is fully managed.
So this will launch
within a few seconds,
and you can get into it and you
can SSH and do all that stuff.
But if you're a
Windows person, I
have a Windows app running here.
You can RDP into that.
So right from the browser,
just RDP and enter my password.
And then, boom, you're in,
and you can do all the Windows
stuff that you need to do.
So that's how you get VMs.
But if you want to install
something on these VMs,
then there's Cloud Launcher.
So if you go here,
Cloud Launcher,
this is, as I mentioned
before, a marketplace
for different
kinds of solutions.
So you can install LAMP stack,
WordPress with one click.
So let's just search for ASP.NET
because I'm a .NET and I just
want to install
ASP.NET framework.
So this solution will
give you a Windows Server,
an ASP.NET framework,
IIS, and SQL Express.
So I'll just say launch
on Compute Engine,
and give this a name.
So let's say ASP.NET GDD Krakow.
Choose my zone as
Europe West again.
I'll keep my machine
type as it is.
And then Windows server,
I'll choose latest one.
And I just keep the
default, hit Deploy,
and now this will
give me an Windows
Server with ASP.NET
framework and IIS
and SQL Server express deployed.
So it will take a couple of
minutes, but it's right there.
So that's that.
But as we mentioned,
virtual machines,
they're kind of old school
now, so we have containers.
And how do you run
containers on Google Cloud?
The easiest way to do
that is App Engine.
So the idea with App Engine
is that you take your code,
you deploy using G-Cloud.
And then from then on,
we take that code, we
create a container
for it in the cloud,
and then we host it on
Container Repository,
and then we deploy
it to App Engine.
So with App Engine,
you get dashboards
by default. You got versions.
So every time you
deploy the application,
you get different versions.
You've got traffic splitting.
So if you have
multiple versions,
you can split the
traffic between them.
And you've got autoscaling.
So by default, it
starts on two VMs,
but then it can autoscale
all the way to 20.
So it's very easy.
It's the easiest way to start
with containers on a cloud.
But at some point, you
might need more control.
Sometimes you want to be able
to define multiple containers,
and you want to be able to
scale them independently.
So you basically want to
create a container cluster.
For that, we have
Container Engine.
So Container Engine is
basically managed Kubernetes.
So we manage the
Kubernetes Master for you.
And with one command, you
can get a Kubernetes cluster
with the Master
and with the nodes.
And then you can just use the
Cube CTL command line tool
to schedule containers.
And we also have some
tools around containers.
So we have Container
Builder, which
is a way to build containers
in the cloud really fast.
And then we have
Container Registry.
So once you've built
your containers,
they get hosted into this
private space for your project.
And then from there, once
you have the container image,
you can deploy it
to Compute Engine,
and then you can
deploy it to App Engine
or you can deploy to Container
Engine and Compute Engine,
anywhere you want basically.
So it's available to
everything you have.
And then finally, my
favorite is Cloud Functions.
So in Cloud Functions, you
create a node.js function
that does some kind
of functionality,
and then you define what
triggers that function.
So it gets triggered
by HTTP calls,
or it gets triggered
by pop-up messages.
And then you just
deploy that and don't
worry about containers or
VMs or anything like that.
Everything is fully
managed for you.
So let's take a quick
look of these as well.
So I already deployed an
App Engine application,
so let's just take
a look at that.
So if you go to App Engine,
first I will click on Versions,
and then you can see that I have
two versions already deployed.
Let's say this Version 3 is
the one getting the traffic,
and it's being run
on two instances.
Version 4 is not
getting any traffic.
I can easily change that.
So I can come here,
do split traffic.
I will do IP-based
traffic splitting.
So I will just add
my version, and then
let's say this will get 50%.
So now each version will
get 50% of the traffic.
So I can do my testing and make
sure that everything works.
So if you go back here,
you'll see that they're both
getting 50% of the traffic.
If I go to Dashboard, this
app is not being used.
So you don't see it much,
but then under here you
see the different versions.
And then I can click
on the version.
And then from here, I can
see the latency traffic,
VM traffic.
So all this stuff
comes for free.
You can even see the instances.
So by default, the apps run
on two instances and these
are regular VMs.
You can add extensions
to them if you want,
but you don't have to because
App Engine kind of manages
this for you.
And this will be autoscaled from
two to 20 if there's a need.
So that's kind of App Engine.
And then if we look
at Container Engine,
I can take the same
container image
and I can deploy it
to Container Engine
and get that managed
by Kubernetes.
So here I have a
cluster already defined.
And if I look under
workloads, in Kubernetes
you basically take
your container
and put it in
what's called a pod.
So I have a pod running
with the same app.
And then once you
have your pod, you
can expose that to
the outside world
using something called Service.
So with Service, you
get a load balancer
and then you get a public IP.
So here I have the IP.
And if I click on it, I have
this Hello World, very exciting
application.
But the point is that
you can take the same app
and basically move it around
from App Engine to Container
Engine really easily.
And finally, what I really
like is Cloud Functions.
So here I have a Cloud
Function that I deployed.
It's a Hello World
kind of Cloud Function.
And if you click on it, it's
running somewhere in the cloud.
I don't know where, but
I don't care anyway.
I can see the
trigger, So this is
a pops-up
topic-triggered function,
Meaning that if there's
a topic, it listens.
And if there's a message
that goes to the topic,
it will be triggered.
I can even see the source of it.
So here, this is my function,
and basically it gets an event
and displays the message.
And you can even test
it right from here.
So in here, I can send
that pops-up message,
and let's say this is message.
And then I'll say, Hello World.
And then test the function.
So this will invoke my function.
And then, when it's
done, I can see the logs,
I can see the output,
everything right here.
It's very easy,
fully managed for me.
So that's that.
Let's go back.
MARC COHEN: So thanks, Mete.
I'd like to briefly
touch on something
that I think is largely
invisible to most people
when they're using
our Cloud Platform.
When you deploy one
of computing elements
that Mete just talked
about, the data
that's moving around, either
from the outside world
into Google's cloud or between
systems within our cloud,
is riding on top of the same
network that powers these seven
products, each with
a billion users.
So we don't have
a separate network
where we're transporting all
the information for your cloud
compute elements
and another network
that we make really good
for our own internal use.
It's the same network fabric,
extremely high performance.
And it's the same
network that's serving up
all those YouTube videos, Gmail,
Google Search, Maps, et cetera.
And the reason it's
so high performance
is that Google has built
its own private network,
massive internal
private network.
It contains dedicated fiber
links around the world.
We even own our own
undersea cables.
I mean, it's not
just the facilities.
A ton of engineering
work over the years
has gone into making it
very high performance, very
low latency.
And you're taking
advantage of all that power
when you're running your
applications in our cloud.
Another kind of key design
piece of our network
is that we've built it
so that when users want
to access our cloud platform--
App Engine apps or Compute
Engine or containers or any
of that stuff--
we've got it designed so that
we route their connections
to the closest point of
presence to that user,
the idea being that
we want to get them
on this high-speed Google
backbone as fast as possible
so that the bulk of
the communication
is taking place over this
very optimized network.
And as a, result we not only
get very high throughput and low
latency, but we get very
predictable response time.
And this is a little map of the
extension of our data centers
around the world.
As you can see, we're
in a lot of areas,
but we're constantly trying
to expand the footprint
to accommodate platform
needs all around the world.
We also have several higher-end
networking capabilities
which I'm not going
to go into today,
but we'll have some
resources at the end
so you can dive into those
if you're interested.
So we've talked about
computing, and we've talked
a little bit about networking.
And now I want to turn to
how you store your data,
something every
application has to do.
And I'm going to try to
cover everything you can
do in that domain in one slide.
So it's going to get
a little bit busy.
We have several products.
It's really kind of like
tools in a tool kit.
And it's just some
really powerful options,
but it's just a matter
of knowing which
one to use for which situation.
The very first one
is in-memory storage.
So this is simply caching
for your App Engine
app or your Compute Engine app.
Think of Redis or Memcache,
something along those lines
as a service.
Then we have the category
of relational databases.
So traditional, SQL-based
relational databases.
And we have Cloud
SQL, which you can
think of as managed
MySQL or Postgres.
So you end up with a bunch of
servers where the images are
maintained for you.
The latest software
is installed.
It's backed up.
But you're still thinking
about database servers
at the end of the day.
And then we have Spanner, which
kind of takes it up a level,
and you really can think
about just the database
independent of any server.
So it's really
database as a service
with a lot of other
nice features as well.
Then on the NoSQL side,
we have Cloud Data Store.
It's a hierarchical
key value store.
It comes out of the
App Engine world
but is now completely
generalized
and can be used from anywhere.
And we've got Cloud
Bigtable, which is also
similarly schema-less and
NoSQL, particularly well suited
for very high-capacity storage
jobs and for a very high-volume
read and write scenarios
like an event log
or page views, detailed
telemetry-type applications.
We have an object store
called Google Cloud Storage.
This was one of the
very first products
that came out as part of
the Google Cloud Platform.
It was the first product
I worked on back in 2011.
It's a very powerful
binary object storage
facility, global
scope replication,
and strong consistency.
Very nice features.
And then we have
block storage device.
So we call these
persistent disks.
This is essentially a
network block device
for attaching it to your VMs.
And the idea is it's
network resident,
and it lives kind of
its own lifecycle.
So if your VM goes down
or you even delete the VM,
your data is still
persistent on that disk.
And you can get those in SSD
format or spinning disks.
Lots more to say about
that, but I'm trying
to for time get through it
And then, of course
BigQuery, which will
we'll see more in a minute.
But that's really good
way to store data,
as well as to analyze
it interactively.
METE ATAMEL: Wow.
That's a lot of storage options.
But I keep hearing
about Spanner.
Can you tell us what
special about Spanner?
MARC COHEN: Funny
you should ask.
I actually have a slide about
Spanner, Mete, thank you.
And it would have been good if
I didn't advance to it early.
So yeah, Cloud
Spanner, it's very new.
It was announced
earlier this year.
And it's a really interesting
new database type.
It's basically a managed,
unlimited scale effectively,
database as a
service in the cloud.
Now, whereas traditional
relational databases
are very strong in terms
of asset compliance
and strong consistency
and data semantics,
they are often
difficult to scale.
A lot of times
you'll see companies
having to shard multiple
concurrent instances
of an RDBMS.
And traditional NoSQL, rather,
is just the inverse of that.
So it scales very easily.
You just add additional
nodes to a cluster,
but you often have
consistency challenges
trying to make sure everything
is strongly consistent
and updates are seen
everywhere at the same time.
Spanner gives you the best of
both worlds in that it gives
you the scalability
of a NoSQL system,
and it gives you the semantics
of a traditional relational
database management system.
And I'd like to
actually just show
you real quick what it looks
like to work with Spanner.
So this is the same
platform, or same console
rather, that Mete
was just showing you,
but I'm in the Spanner domain.
And when we're
working with Spanner,
we create things
we call instances.
And instances are simply
collections of databases,
but they're completely abstract.
I don't have to think about
how the software is configured
or anything like that.
Within the instance,
I create a database.
So I'm going to take this
sort of imaginary example
that I'm a university
administrator,
and I need to keep track
of the database for all
the students in the university.
So I've created a database
I call University.
And I have two tables in
that database, departments--
so these are the
different subject areas,
they have a department
ID, a budget, and a name--
and student-- so these
are an enumeration
of all the students.
So I have a department
ID, which is inherited.
So every student is
affiliated with a department.
Then I have an SID.
That's my student ID,
unique key for this table,
and a student name.
Now, one of the really
nice things about Spanner
is I can dynamically
change the schema.
Let's say I decide I want to
add a column to this table.
So I'll say Edit Schema.
Anybody have something
they would like
to add to the student record?
What's the attribute that
causes college students the most
stress?
METE ATAMEL: GPA
MARC COHEN: Let's
add a GPA column.
Let's make it a float.
We'll add that and say Save.
And it's now
updating the schema.
There can be tons of data there.
It's going to update all
the data that I have now
as well as make it possible
for me to store new data.
And the database is
continuing to run.
There's no downtime.
So it's not stopping
ongoing operations.
It's continuing to serve
requests as we speak.
And while it's doing
that schema update,
I'm going to show
you another thing.
Let's say I'm wildly successful
with my new database,
and I have more load
than I can possibly take.
And I just told you earlier
that it's really scalable.
So what I can do is go
to the Instance page.
There we go.
And I can say Edit Instance.
And I can simply change
the number of nodes
from one to three.
Save.
And I now have tripled
my capacity that easily.
I now have three times as
much database serving capacity
as I did before.
I think the schema
update is done.
As you can see, being able
to just to turn that knob
is really one of
the major advantages
of Spanner's scalability.
METE ATAMEL: All right.
So now let's talk about big
data in the last four minutes
that we have.
So big data at Google
started with MapReduce.
Back in the day, we were
trying to process lots of data,
and then there was
a paper on MapReduce
that basically explained
how to take lots of data
and break that down
into small chunks then
map them to different
machines, and then
apply some kind of aggregation
and get a result back.
So after MapReduce,
there was a lot
of innovation within Google.
So there were things like
Bigtable, Flume, and Spanner.
So these were either papers
or internal implementations
that people couldn't
use outside Google.
Because of this, we had a
bunch of Apache projects
that were influenced
by these papers.
So we had a Hadoop, which
is the open source MapReduce
implementation.
We had things like
Spark and Pig and Hive.
And because of this
split in innovation,
we had two products
on Google Cloud.
We had Dataflow, which is
basically the state-of-the-art
data processing pipeline
that came up at Google,
and now we are making
it available to people.
But at the same time, if
you're already using Hadoop
and if you're
already using Spark,
there's something
else called Dataproc.
It's a way to run your Spark
or other jobs on Google Cloud.
MARC COHEN: So if we think
about the big data world,
the typical kind of
thing we want to do
is to have a
processing pipeline.
And so I'm going to just briefly
walk through that pipeline.
The first phase would
be capturing your data.
And we'll come up
with an example
of how you might do this.
Imagine you wanted to track all
of the activity on Wikipedia.
So imagine you had an event
firing, like an HTTP post
or something like that,
every time somebody pulled up
any article in Wikipedia.
Cloud Pub/Sub would be a
perfect example of something
to use for that because it's a
very high capacity repository.
It's a message queue.
And so it can then
publish those events
to any number of
downstream consumers.
We might feed that downstream
into data prep, which
is a way to cleanse your
data, add semantic checking,
and rearrange things.
And that might
feed into Dataflow,
which can be a very flexible
pipeline building tool.
You can use Apache Beam to
program the processing there.
And it can also operate
on either large batches
of data or streaming data.
So you could actually use it
in sort of a real-time fashion.
The output of that would
be the processed data,
and we might want to store
it in one of the storage
facilities I mentioned earlier.
We could do real-time
analysis on it using BigQuery,
and I'll actually show you an
example of that in a second.
And then we might want to
actually take that data
and work on it interactively
in a more user-friendly way.
So we have Cloud Datalab,
which gives us the ability
to use Jupyter Notebooks
to interactively play
with the data.
And we also have
Data Studio, which
is a very nice tool for
building interactive dashboards
and other visualizations.
So let's hop over to
the console again.
This is a different
part of the console,
but this is for
running BigQuery.
And I've actually preloaded a
month's worth of Wikipedia page
views into this
particular database.
So here's my query.
I can format it nicely.
I'm going to turn off used
cache results because they
don't want to cheat.
It'll come back blindingly
fast, but it won't be true.
So I'm going to run this query.
What this is doing is
scanning every line
in the table of this
database, and it's looking
for occurrences of Krakow.
Because the o can be
written in different ways
depending on language, I've
used a regular expression
to avoid that.
So not only am I scanning
every row in the table.
I'm running a regular
expression on every single row
in this table.
I get my output.
And if we look at
the job information,
we see that it's scanned
almost 50 gigabytes of data.
And the query explanation
shows us the number of rows.
It's scanned 1.8
billion with a B rows.
It didn't just scan them all.
It ran a regular
expression on them all.
So I hope this
gives you a sense--
and I didn't mention
the punchline is
it was under five seconds.
In under five seconds, we ran
regular expression queries
on 1.8 billion rows of data.
Hopefully that gives you a
sense of some of the power
and speed you get with BigQuery.
METE ATAMEL: Great.
And then last but not
least, machine learning.
So machine learning is big, and
I think this graph shows why.
This is the amount
of machine learning
at Google and all the
different products that
uses machine learning.
So you see an exponential
growth in the last few years.
So when it comes to
using machine learning
in your applications,
you basically
have two ways of using
machine learning.
The easy way is let someone
build a model, machine learning
model, and give you an API
and use that machine learning
from your application.
So you're not really building
machine learning yourself.
You're just consuming someone
else's machine learning model.
And then in the other
model, sometimes
the given model is not
good enough or maybe
you want to customize things.
So you need to actually create
your own machine learning
model.
So for that, you can create
and serve your own machine
learning model.
You're using things
like TensorFlow.
So in terms of using
models at Google Cloud,
we have a bunch of
machine learning
APIs for different
kinds of models
that we've built over the years.
So we have Speech API
for speech recognition.
We have Vision API
for image recognition,
and a bunch of other things.
So basically, we built these
models all these years,
and we are just making
it available to you
with an API call.
And I just want to
show you really quickly
a demo for the Vision API.
So in Vision API,
you pass an image,
and then you get
information about the image
using machine learning.
So here I have a
picture of a cute cat.
Sorry for the dog lovers.
I don't have a dog picture.
But in this one, I passed
this image to Vision API,
and then I got a JSON back.
But if you look at the
JSON in a graphical way,
the Vision API figured
out that this is a cat,
and it even figured
out that this
is a British short-haired cat.
And then from there, it
can extract the color.
It can extract whether
this is an adult image
or a medical image.
If you pass in more complicated
things, like a stadium,
it figures that it's
a baseball stadium.
It picks up the text
from different places.
It even picks up
people's expressions.
So it picked up this
guy and then the fact
that he is joyful, and it even
knows where the location is.
So you can see
the kind of things
that you can get
from Vision API.
MARC COHEN: Thanks.
So underlying all
of those products
that you saw, that exponential
curve that Mete showed,
is TensorFlow.
And for those who haven't
already encountered it,
it's a framework for building
machine learning models
that Google open sourced
almost two years ago.
It's now become more of
an industry standard, kind
of communal open
source project--
tremendous contributions
and tremendous popularity.
It's particularly
well-suited for building
complex deep-learning
models and neural networks
and those sorts of things.
And when you start to
get into that domain,
you really need power.
You need computational power.
A lot of those
models you can't just
run on a laptop or something.
And that's where Cloud Machine
Learning Engine comes in.
So we've built this
product to make
it really easy to build and
serve models, TensorFlow
models, in the cloud.
So the idea here is you get a
fully-managed infrastructure.
You build your model,
prototype it perhaps
on your workstation
or wherever, and then
you upload it to the
cloud, and you'll
benefit from very optimized
environment for training
and for serving your requests.
The other advantage you get is
the TensorFlow processing unit,
which is optimized hardware
we've built ourselves,
custom A6, that helps do the
Tensor math orders of magnitude
faster than we've been
able to do in the past.
The result of all
this is that we're
making it easier for people
to build complex models so
that you can really
focus on the model
and not worry about things
like, where do I run it,
how do I get all the CPUs I
need, how do I get the GPUs,
how do I coordinate parallel
processing of models.
A lot of that stuff is
being made really easy
so that you can just focus
on what you care about,
which is your own model.
METE ATAMEL: And that's it.
So that was a lot
of information.
The main page that you want to
remember is cloud.google.com,
but there's other links as well.
We also have a free trial
if you want to try out.
It's cloud.google.com/free.
You get $300 for 12 months.
So don't take our word for it.
Try it out and see what you
like and what you don't like.
MARC COHEN: Yeah.
And I want to add that that's
really the best way to learn.
I mean, we're doing
our best to tell you
in a very short period of
time what it's all about,
but I find learn by doing
is a great way to go.
So avail yourself
of the free tier.
Try some things out.
Try building something.
We think you'll
have a lot of fun,
and maybe you'll build the
next amazing application.
And with that,
thank you very much.
METE ATAMEL: Thank you.
MARC COHEN:
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]..